for the past several months Trump has
been constantly bringing up the topic of
negative interest rates and that the US
should use them he has stated the
Federal Reserve should get our interest
rates down to zero or less and that he
could get used to negative interest
rates the recent situation has only
prompted him to push for it even more so
what even our negative interest rates
and why does Trump insist on them
well negative interest rates are when
the central bank or the Federal Reserve
pays banks and institutions interest to
borrow money similarly they charge banks
and institutions interest to hold their
money this will slowly go down the
ladder to consumers who will also be
charged interest for keeping money in a
savings account while they can borrow
money for really low interest rates
possibly even be paid to borrow money
but how could this be beneficial to
anyone banks can't even make money on
giving out loans and the average person
loses money by simply holding their
money in a savings account well first of
all this will lead to a higher GDP GDP
is calculated by adding together
consumer spending investing government
spending and net exports when people and
institutions are being charged to simply
hold their money they're much more
likely to spend the money to avoid being
charged interest the brightest will
invest in real estate stocks bonds and
so on and so forth while others will
simply blow the money and use negative
interest rates as an excuse but either
way this will increase consumer spending
and investing thus increasing national
GDP furthermore when companies invest
into new products and open up new
manufacturing plants this will create
more job linking more people making more
money this creates positive feedback
loops in which people make more money
and then spend more money and throughout
all of this the government will also be
pulling in more revenue from the
spending and investing going on this
includes increased sales tax revenue
capital gains tax property tax and so on
and so forth
thus negative interest rates will
increase consumer spending investments
and government spending which will in
turn inflate the national GDP moving on
negative interest rates will also
encourage people to take out more loans
which if used right can lead to more
prosperity for instance a person looking
at take advantage of this opportunity
may buy their first house or another
rental property or maybe they take the
leap and open up a local business
following up negative interest rates
give a country an export advantage when
a country implements negative interest
rates the currency becomes less
favorable on the foreign exchange market
thus causing a currency to lose value
this
would increase exports as US goods would
be comparatively cheaper to foreign
countries at the same time foreign goods
would be comparatively more expensive to
US residents thus decreasing imports
this combination will increase in net
exports out of a country and again help
the country's GDP so essentially
negative interest rates to stimulate
market activity to inflate GDP and this
is especially useful in a recession a
side benefit is that this creates a
golden opportunity for many investors
however there are many risks to be aware
of as well starting off banks will be
less motivated to lend out money as I
won't make much interest from them
anyways they will continue to give out
money as long as interest rates for
borrowing are positive but when they're
only making one percent interest they
tend to lend only to say for individuals
for instance they might increase their
credit and down payment requirements
because the returns are simply not worth
lending to pesky individuals as a result
this will actually decrease the amount
of people that can benefit from low
borrowing rates also this could lead to
a concentration of capital under larger
banks who can afford to charge less
interest thousands of smaller banks
could collapse through the funds and the
reserves drying up furthermore this
could lead to large-scale the query
concerns for all financial institutions
when everyone is trying to withdraw
money either to spend invest or stash
under their mattress and everyone is
trying to take out loans banks will have
trouble funding all of these activities
and if too many people withdraw their
money this will result in a banking
panic leading to an even worse economic
situation a solution to this issue would
be the only charge negative interest on
funds that exceed a certain amount and
continue giving positive interest for
funds under that amount this will
prevent people who don't have much money
Starwood's from spending a little money
they have the negative interest will
only affect people who have several
hundred thousands of dollars in savings
accounts who really should be investing
all that excess money anyways as a
result if negative interest rates are
implemented in moderation it should
affect the economy in a positive way as
this is not just some crazy plan crumped
out of over the weekend negative
interest rates have been implemented
around the world starting in Switzerland
the Swiss first implemented negative
interest rates during the 2008 financial
recession and if we take a look at her
GDP graph it's as if the recession never
even happened as a dip is small enough
to be explained by natural variation
since then Switzerland has made it a
habit to implement negative interest
rates
whenever the economy is on a downturn
and as Switzerland has one of the
strongest if not the strongest economy
in the world this practice of using
negative interest rates has caught on
across the world and this is where
President Trump got the idea to
implement negative interest rates in the
US but one thing to remember is that all
the countries in which negative interest
rates have been successful have small
homogenous populations for a country as
big and diverse as the u.s. negative
interest rates may cause more harm than
good but we can't tell unless we try if
you guys thought this video provided a
good analysis of the pros and cons of
negative interest rates then make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one